pense c'est que nous faisons
régulièrement la chasse à la langue de
bois se dira ce vocabulaire souvent plus
compréhensible de l'administration mais
même des hommes politiques pardon
messieurs
mais il faut que vous sachiez que vos
églises rennes ne comprennent pas
toujours vous répondre vos réponses à
leurs lettres alors de grâce ne leur
parlez pas trop de corps constitués ou
autre terminologie de ce style regardez
le résultat tel que l'a observé gérard
pas bio grâce à ses opinions sur rue
c'est le terme que nous employons par
dérision les rues aujourd'hui étant
celle d'angers mais deux tours
dans les grands corps de l'état qu'est
ce que vous verriez monsieur bourgoin
pourquoi parce qu'on voit toujours que
toi que tu présidents ou des choses
comme ça on doit toujours très
beaucoup plus forte et beaucoup plus
grand que savez vous mademoiselle des
corps constitués
c'est là ce sont des corps constitués à
votre avis qu'est ce que ce serait c'est
quand l'enfant à naître mais papa va
naître mais ce fort le scellant peillon
comment imaginez-vous la dissolution de
la chambre à la dissolution lancée
du mal à voir ce qu'on voulait dire par
des solutions de la sambre pas si c'est
pour réparer un trou dans une chambre à
air
est ce que j'en sais moi une fois qu'on
a trouvé le trou il ya des petits trappe
en faire on gratte la chambre et on met
de la conne et on une rustine film je
suis simplement pas quand je vous parle
des relations extérieures vous voyez ce
que je veux vous dire vous parler des
droits là j'ai des relations après
disons dans un ménage ou quoi
les relations des jeunes avec jeune
fille pourquoi à votre avis avant
justement être abattus
je pense qu à partir du moment où les
mario on doit avoir une vie raisonnable
que l'on doit faire un couple uni et
chacun doit apporter sa contribution
le palais bourbon ah non pas du tout
voyez ce que c'est
welch ou est-ce que ça mais moi je crois
pas que ça mais quand je vois pas là de
whisky bière
pas de discours enfin quand je vous
parle de palais
le whisky toute manière comment
imaginez-vous un portefeuille de
ministre monsieur michaud palmer a
affirmé celui d'un ministre est de
l'étang crocodiles des serpents
crocodiles
pour une matière disons
une homme lequel celui d'un ouvrier et
puis il ya certainement d'argent dedans
enfin vous n'êtes pas pour le changement
de cabinet fréquents non non quand s'est
entretenu maintenu je veux dire quand
l'entretien était fréquemment ses dires
bah c'est à dire disons que ça soit
propre camp soit propre était alors de
temps en temps si par exemple achat ne
fonctionne plus ou moins bien
l'affairé paraît aussi vous dire une
fois encore que nos opinions sur rue
sont rigoureusement authentique et que
nous n'avons aucune façon l'intention de
tourner en dérision qui que ce soit au
contraire nous sommes toujours frappé
par l'extrême gentillesse de nos
interlocuteurs
il est vrai que si l'on nous pose est à
nous mêmes une question aussi abrupte et
surprenante que celle déjà repas bio
comme ça où près d'une rue nous serions
peut-être bien embarrassé pour être la
note